please welcome our friend Kristen Schaal
[Applause]
gorgeous you look beautiful
is that what you're doing now is it
because everyone has their own thing
that they're doing you know rather than
shaking hands right now is that yours
it just happened in this moment oh
really I invented it I passed it on to
you and now the whole world can have it
yeah no not at all yeah so some people
are doing they're doing the foot the
foot thing you know and then today
someone at my kids school I went in for
a school conference kids not kids not
cutting it and military school for him
but one of the teachers went I I was
forgot for a second cuz you forget and I
went to shake hands man oh and I went oh
right and he went he did me the the
Spock live long and prosper
so he's fired I don't have to work again
yeah so everyone's back their own way of
handling this I mean I think the but
Leigh is good I know that it's really
scary they moved the my spy domestic
release back to the day after your
birthday day after my birthday yes
but worldwide it's coming out anyway so
if you're in Hong Kong you can still see
it on Friday the 13th of March okay I
was going to fly to Hong Kong to see
your movie that's what I intend to do
I'm going to do I'm a huge fan I am a
huge fan of yours and you know that
thanks for a long time I'm kind of
excited that I am your first guest this
is the first time that I've ever been
your first guest which worries me a
little bit about your show but it's
still well we only have the bottom the
barrel and came up with sha sha not
first no you are the only guest that's
why you're the first guest
more special well you got those flower
brothers are coming on but I know and I
swear score brothers you know I don't I
think they're coming out to do comedy
you're the only one I'm sitting down and
talking to I refuse to sit and speak
with this Barbara oh he won't speak to
the Sklar is there
with dad nothing happened there lovely
people that's a joke but still resent
them a little bit when they come out
yeah they have to earn your laughs from
a very dark place